COMMITTEES CALLED THE ORDER
PLEASE BE ADVISED AN AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDINGS BEING MADE OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS. THAT IS
ALSO BEING TELEVISED SECRETARY
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WE I'M
HERE HERE THAT LARA YEAH. HERE
KAMLAGER WE LIVING MAIENSCHEIN
YEAH ABOUT THAT HERE. WE'RE
WELFARE. OUR. I CAN'T WATER. WE
REMAIN LEVINE I AM TRYING TO
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS FIVE
MATHIS IRONIC RIGHT NOW I'M
EXACTLY WHO RUN FOUR YEARS ALL
RIGHT SIR A BOB HI HOUSING THAT
MOTION PASSES THIS RULES
COMMITTEE IS IT ACTUALLY I WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN. FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THAT ON THANK YOU.
RELATED LIKE THAT- YEAH THREE.
LEE HIGH.
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I'D.
WITH BOARD. YEAH HI FLOOR.
FLORA HI.